some breaking news to bring you now and
in the past hour Liz trust has confirmed
that five British Nationals who are
being held by pro-russian forces in
eastern Ukraine have been released as
part of a prisoner swap deal brokered by
the Saudi Crown Prince well we can cross
to our chief correspondent John Craig
who's at the foreign office for us for
us hello to you uh John what more do you
know about how this came about
well this announcement came from the
Prime Minister a short time ago and as
you said clearly the Saudis Have Been
instrumental in this move uh making the
announcement Liz trust said in a tweet
hugely welcome news that five British
Nationals held by russian-backed proxies
in eastern Ukraine are being safely
returned ending months of uncertainty
and suffering for them and their
families she said I thank president
yolenski for his efforts to secure the
release of detainees and Saudi Arabia
for their assistance and she concluded
Russia must end the ruthless
exploitation of prisoners of war and
civilian detainees for political ends
now in addition to that James cleverley
the foreign secretary also welcoming
this move
um she taught he talks about the five
British Nationals he says prisoners of
war from other countries held by
russian-backed proxies have also been
returned and he said though that one he
mentioned one who has not and has uh
died Paul Yuri that is
um but the campaign to free these
Nationals in Parliament here in the UK
has been led by Robert genre now he's a
former cabinet minister MP for Newark
just rejoined the government he has
campaigned for one of his constituents
Aiden Aslan now he was one or he is one
of the five
um he said that he's delighted that
they've been finally been released
um he told the story about Aiden he's
released a statement from Aiden's family
in 2018 he moved to Ukraine he met his
girlfriend eventually settled down uh
there he decided to join the Ukrainian
Marine served in his unit for nearly
four years he is not contrary to the
kremlin's propaganda a volunteer a
mercenary or a spy says the statement Mr
generic has released when he was raised
Mr Janet was Raising this in the Commons
in June when there was a court hearing
Mr uh generic referring to the
sentencing of Mr Aslin and others to
death said it was a disgusting Soviet
era Style Show trial and the latest
reminder of the depravity of Putin's
regime well clearly the Saudis have been
key in what has happened a lot of
diplomatic efforts Beyond behind behind
the scenes clearly the president
yelensky and his governments have helped
here and there is immense relief here at
the foreign office and in the British
government and of course the families of
those five britons who have now we
understand been released